This one great thing
about Google Web Toolkit
is that it allows us
to develop our web client
in a statically typed
language.
We have a lot of tools
that help us to do
static analysis.
And they, you know,
find bugs
before we even run
the compiler.
It's still pretty difficult
to debug a web client
in the web browser.
And so the more bugs
we can find
before we get
to that point,
the better off we are.
Another thing that's great
is sharing the same language
between the client
and the server.
We do other parts
of our project
where we actually
have to translate
between Java and ActionScript,
and it's cumbersome
and the source
of a lot of bugs.
And not having to do that
with the web client
is a huge bonus.
One problem that we face
is how to make
our Ajax application
web indexable.
Right now it looks like a sort
of big pile of Java script
to everyone--
or to the web search engines.
And that's not
very useful.
Most people do some sort
of hacky work around
where they generate,
like, a second copy
of their whole website
that looks good
to a search engine.
But that's
a whole lot of work
and a big pain in the neck
to maintain.
And it would be really great
if GWT could help
to solve this problem.